hey Gary you're seeing a lot of
platforms we've kind of trying to cross
functionality like Tick Tock Implement
be real sort of functionality I see an
Instagram now it could be with be real
and do more videos Centric stuff do you
think it's gonna end up being everyone
doing everything I think everybody will
try everything if there's a standalone
app that they think is a feature but
some will stick and some won't for
example Snapchat stories Snapchat comes
out stories Works Instagram ads it it's
stuck that was like that big moment a
lot of you probably remember this what
about Clubhouse when Clubhouse got hot I
made a video that said everyone's gonna
try to make this a feature everybody did
Facebook included Instagram all of them
it was Twitter spaces that stuck so I
think with be real or anything we see
for the next half decade all the leaders
will try to implement it and some will
have it stick because it worked for them
and they did a good job and some won't
and that will be the constant flow that
we see Austin